hello everyone welcome to another
episode of red lips orange car I'm
joined by mati sleeve greetings welcome
Jerry I'm so happy to be here I got real
real excited when you asked and I very
happy to be a part of this good because
kind of groovy concept for a podcast
this is wholly original back because I
knew that I wanted to do a podcast and I
was like what do I want it to be and I
was just like grab bagging at random
ideas I'm like shooting them on modding
and just being like what the hell should
I do
well this stimulus is you make the cut
I'm curious there were a lot yeah if I
go to my tags like we owe one was that I
wanted to do you know the games oh yeah
I wanted to do werewolf like with like
six people and just have that be the
podcast so like mafia / yeah yeah I
wanted to do that but then it was like
[Music]
yes so - connection is from Milwaukee's
Craigslist Milwaukee's oh he I did right
Jared no boy he is in Wisconsin that's
where I went to college and so when I'm
looking at things sometimes I think this
one is all in caps which I've really
liked since last week I like I like a
just a spring that's all in caps
it's the thick girl at Menards same big
money
so it's saving money but I'm so glad
you're okay but it's thick in its th I
see see see several scenes several seas
do you know what Menard says no are this
is where you gonna say big money save
big money Bernards Menards is a
department store in the Midwest where
are you going by construction
it's like Quincy Pose yes like a
hardware store and the Walmart baby yeah
huh yeah Bunny's is like a popular hog
West oh but it's particularly popular
because they do really good sausage
sizzles but some recent awesome wait a
moment please
Oh sausage there's always way you like
cook a sausage
and you like sell it for a doll and you
like put it in bread and you put tomato
sauce on it and it's usually the money
goes towards that's just I want to be
like something that happens outside
Burning Man
no they're different but the point that
I was going to get to is there was a
recent sausage sizzle controversy in
Australia because it was too hot in
Melbourne for Bunnings to do the sausage
sizzle so they canceled them outside
girl with three C's very different you
know like the noggin clay Church thi CC
yeah I think yeah like okay it's like
there was no care yeah it's Jesse's its
dick
yeah I think well I know it means but I
always and when it doesn't have a que it
means like in a sexual way like damn she
Kobe
the assumption is she has a posterior
cavity yes yeah and she's probably like
purchasing Hardwick so like I love
crafty in geometry love I don't think I
don't let's just get to the I really
feel like to understand what's happening
here I'm probably putting too much in
yeah Richard cheese's cover of disturb
yes that's what I like I am like I'm a
funny-looking person I like a giant big
fat body but have a really tiny but yeah
you said no yes yeah you nothing I
nothing like I have this giant like I
have like 200 pounds of body on top of
like 40 pound legs are you like swole
kylo Ren III come
yeah like swole kylo Ren
he's got smaller body yes I'm gonna mean
[ __ ] off
I saw you while you were walking at work
the way your ass moves when you walk
it's a blessing I can't stop thinking
about you I even see you in my dreams I
saw you suck your thumb and it makes me
wonder what else can that mouth do
Menards I would love to take you out
sometime please text me at and then I'm
not gonna say his phone number but I
want to show you guys for reference he
has his phone number and he writes some
of the numbers out Oh
he writes the numbers out some of them
are written out and then some of them
are actual numbers did he also have a he
has a week vacation he has a winky face
again
so mostly this was like to me this is
sort of I like the fact that he screamed
in his head line of the thick Menards
yeah I like the fact that there's
several seas but I appreciated what's to
say big money he doesn't say which
menon's he doesn't say no he says Brett
water
the thing I want to talk about is I
don't think any of this would work on
the human beings at Menards I just don't
I don't think this is his pitch that
this being a picture so the thing I sort
of as he's been watching her for a bit
don't think screaming all of this at
them and then saying I like the way you
bit your thumb while you were working
which maybe she just bit her now I don't
think I think this is a way to like well
approach a human being no because that's
that's the thing where this is the stuff
that you think but then you don't say
out loud this is the stuff that you're
like one of what else she can do with
that mouth is not a thing that you say -
arras and you're actually trying to hit
on right so it's like he just like
posted his internal monologue he clearly
didn't talk to her but he could have he
didn't talk to it doesn't want a
relationship it's purely sex is he in a
relationship oh yeah picric thick Rick's
good that's good thanks tikrit then you
give everyone in thick Rick I'm pretty
sure it's probably trademarked by
someone in the thicket of Slick Rick
that's a rapper dick I don't know what
happened there no I actually believe
slick very private dick is in fact
I think it's I thik thi CCC Ric Ric CC
all right so this is thick Rick Rick
Rick alright so and I think that he is
approached her in this way because he's
in a relationship where doesn't want a
relationship and just wants to sleep
with us because he could have gone up to
impressed I think that you're right and
this would walk with a very small amount
of people again is saying the things
he's thinking out loud implying that
he's watching her like enough to like
see her like suck on have gum and watch
the way that she walks it's a little bit
creepy yes I feel like this is a creepy
brunch I totally understand II like I
went to a place this one was working
there and I was attracted to them like I
get that like that's happened I think to
all of us I think he's wrong necessarily
for doing that it's the saying you're
trying to say it yes it's the creepy I
do you think he's trying to actually
make a connection looking at miss
connections when you read through them I
get the impression about 78% of them off
the hip are not about actually any hope
of finding the person they're about
wishing you'd found the person they are
they're almost sometimes awful poetry
but they're bad - beautifully depending
on the moment poetic expressions this is
one of those and while it be in
articulate this is a guy who's been
thinking about it for a while city's
dreaming about this so I get that he
would just want to be like I just want
to write this down and have it out there
yeah this is gonna happen right I mean
the weird thing is some of these are
like two ships passing in the night so
some of this is I saw you in an airport
you have no idea where that person is
going and you chances are you never
gonna see their item he knows this girl
works at the Menards in Brown Deer
Wisconsin like I think this is a do
dudes like fantasizing about sleeping
with someone that's why my head went to
I think he's in a relationship
mmm he's like well but he did put his
number there so he's identifiable
kudos to thick right before putting
himself out there I don't think this is
gonna work I don't think he wants it to
walk and I think Jarrod's right in if he
if this is a fantasy yeah if he wanted
to he would just go back and talk to her
right I mean we live in a weird age were
for almost first time in history there's
there's an easy
for taking our impulsive feelings
whether they be wise or not realistic or
not gross or not depending on the moment
and just throwing them on to a forum and
being like well yours are I'm thinking
right now once you polish it's out there
yeah I do think some people post
something with the intention of of
course they do i I mean I why would you
not I I brought up the concepts of this
podcast at a bar the other night and
literally a person next to me was like
my best friend and his wife met yeah
this connection I joined them
tangentially yes they're at the bar
they're at the bar I go to every Tuesday
for trivia that's how I should totally
try and it that's that's a great idea
yeah they should you should make that
happen
yeah I think sick Rick is thinking out
loud and I don't know put his number in
in Arabic doing wheels on walls no we
probably should call I think that's I
think that's a colossal my phone's in
airplane mode I can't do that but at
least Jarrod like you said you saved big
money yeah that's right maybe you got a
nice like pressure washer that's way out
all right so mine is uh I picked a joke
one and this is one that's actually like
gotten some viral attention so some
people might have heard of this one to
the girl who took a gamble on a thot and
lost 22 we met okay for yes we met on
Craigslist so I'm hoping that this post
finds you I know that it could quite
possibly be the most humiliating first
date you've ever been on but I'm willing
to look past that stuff about chemistry
though at some point in life everyone
has gambled on a fought in a loss it
just happened to be on the first date
and the passenger seat of my car please
don't feel bad the package I sent with
pepto the next day and a note that said
first dates are always crapshoot call me
was meant to be funny not offensive I
have gambled who Nevadan lost on
multiple occasions this is basically him
saying that he's he doesn't want to feel
bad I'm the last person to judge you for
crapping your pants in fact I'm
impressed by your bulbous the timing on
the other hand could have been a tad bit
better like when you're not sitting on a
heated leather seat what I'm trying to
say is that if you want to go on a date
again I would be more than happy to take
you someplace where we can get a meal
that is high in fiber and less taxing on
the gesture correct and wait you're cold
tap PS if you show yourself on purpose
to any evening
Touche hahahaha this is this guy I met
this girl they went on a date I assume
like they didn't have each other's phone
numbers and he's posted this publicly to
be like hey I know that you shot
yourself when you thought that you were
just going to fought while sitting next
to me in my car and that's very
embarrassing but I want to give you
another chance
first point I think that this is really
sweet like just a genuinely very sweet
thing to say
second of all no [ __ ] way that goal
is ever gonna see him ever again I think
that there is a there's a universe where
this could be sweet but not on
Craigslist this is a sweet senator
having like he did you would hot a date
with her how does you know that has our
number it has four texts right so in
this situation it does say that he he
like delivered the package to her I kind
of yeah doesn't have her number we know
that he was I don't put words into his
mouth but I have a feeling that
something could have been delivered on
paper or in person or just that he chose
to do on Facebook because I don't
understand well it could be that doing
it publicly in it getting attention
again is a thing that is kind of sweet
and like could be enough to actually
reach her and be like okay the students
now like blowing up like maybe doesn't
the BuzzFeed article or something yeah
maybe I should pay attention to this I
think that's not a terrible strategy I
mean I friends that got engaged on a
Jumbotron at a hockey game
I don't know there's a way different
than sharp I never problem with
scatological stuff in general I've been
married not normal I mean I think that's
fine no I've been married for a very
long time to this day the bathroom doors
closed between us yeah I respect that
yeah that's that's us we hope you have
to be very comfortable peeing in that
bathroom right now with the door open it
wasn't like wide open it was just not
close he's fair Marty if you want to pee
in front of me it's okay but I don't
want to sleep with you I don't know I I
think that there is a strategy in you I
think this is very sweet I think that if
I was that goal that I would literally
never see that man again in my entire
life no matter how good the date was
like I don't yeah okay so I don't
there's a lot times I lucky enough to be
healthy enough to not have any problems
and like I've been sort of in charge of
my so that's the thing is I had I dated
a girl in college and early college who
had ideas and so like that was that like
we never we never had a scenario like
this but it's totally a like I don't
know [ __ ] your pants is funny but I
also like that's that's an illness like
that's public again why why why tell the
story in front of he's clearly trying to
get the attention yeah which is more
important than relationships well the
relationship is not going to walk unless
he gets the attention is the thing looks
like he's I think he's trying and she's
ignoring him because she said target and
you're writing this this could be rude
if he had mentioned in my name I think
it would be terrible the fact that he
doesn't makes it okay I think yeah I
totally get your also I don't like his
humble brag about how his seats are
leather and warm well can you imagine
doing that on the seat to be thrown I am
I haven't shaved my pants probably since
I was two oh I am way way more likely I
don't think that he's ever gonna see
that way way more likely to go out with
a guy he has heated leather seats that's
real yeah absolutely
I haven't nice decipher I haven't I
didn't shave myself as I was too I peed
I think I was at high school and it was
we were we were driving up to my uncle's
cabin and I thought I could hold it all
the way up to the cabin and I literally
peed my pants on the drive boy and I was
like a bear I was a sober high school
boys laughing - what's an inn Chrissy
Teigan like tweeted the other day about
doing that thing what you really need to
be doing that thing when you need to pee
and you're like running to the bathroom
and then she's like oh my god it's about
to come out and then yeah so the trip
and she was like I have to be ahead to
pee I have to pee whoa close the door
behind her turned around her body was
already like we are peeing and she
forgot that they had I went to get
coffee and I like sat down for a bit and
then I definitely sat on both I think it
was like a stranger I definitely said
him he might have a dog because it
wasn't the cafe that has dogs around at
all I don't know but I definitely sat on
poop and I had to walk back to the
office with just some things poop on on
my pants and change my pants it was not
great yeah that would I do believe in my
kid so while my body probably was Edna I
have a problem at a point like I
probably would have guarded the top
floor of the building and considered
jumping like being touched by is bad I
don't like my own feces being around
somebody else is unthinkable yeah I you
know one of those people like if I ever
have a child but I'm like changing the
diaper probably to puke on the baby like
insert it really listen great and I
proceeded to vomit dogs like I choose
divers and our story finalists why did I
try this - because I
I have family members who are babies no
I just think like oh yeah anything like
smells bad or slightly old like I don't
makes me feel sick
it just does and so I have our time with
that but but poop especially sides but
I'm not the skies so you won this guy
would you still go on a date with this
girl if she had put this up next year
absolutely cuz they said like you said
they had great chemistry yeah I'm
thinking back to some things that happen
dates but I say that that I would do
that in this case you know as much as I
dislike poop but I can think about
situations my own pet and one of the
date wants with a with a young lady who
accidentally tore my toenail off Oh what
what and I gotta be honest the
relationship how do you what are you
what my I had broken my toenail on the
corner of a giant inflatable sumo
wrestling ring in college just one does
yes yeah and a you knows big inflatable
like bounce houses you know sell metal
frames I had been pushed by someone and
fallen just actually my future wife
pushed me in just such a way that I
smashed my toe on one of the pipes and
busted it and my toenail split yeah no
no a couple of days this is when we were
not dating
um we were friends for a long time
before we did it
couple years later I was out with a very
nice old lady and we were dancing
and I'm a terrible dancer and the young
lady stepped on my toe very awkwardly
and then kind of fell and ground by
accident and dug it in and then did that
runs everyone is nice young lady she was
I always come with that's the problem oh
yeah and the
my helmet erupted off was kind of
associated with this I shall have it on
my head I got that so the most
interesting thing that has ever happened
me on a date that I can think of I'm
like very oblivious to bad things so one
time I don't realize until someone else
it's like that was bad not the one that
comes to my mind is that there was this
guy that I had liked for a really long
time his name is Declan Jones shout out
to Declan no I'd say I still have in
this Facebook friend that's entirely
possible but he could find this and I we
went to the movies and I have like
wanted to kiss him for the whole time
and he hasta kissed me and I guess we
both leaned in and then just ended up
hugging because neither of us like
really committed to the kiss so you like
us too but then we just hugged
anyway Netta kissed by the shopbot
okay make up that Greg and shot bud all
right yeah I searched very hard for mine
um now I'm an old man I have been dating
the same person since the 20th century I
was talking about to certainly not with
Marty so not a lot of miss connections
for me but I don't have fun I searched a
lot I was really hoping to find
something in Reno
that was perfect his reactions like them
not Vegas but somehow linked really like
sad Vegas I'm really excited to do an
episode of this poor Custer in III right
no comment
just do with the shaggy Romeo no no no
no great but ultimately I just love like
the girl playing call of duty at the
Activision but I do love this one
ultimately I chose my own current
residence the delightful San Francisco
suburb of Redwood City and this miss
connection is set in this region I chose
it at the DMV Beauty Department of Motor
Vehicles for a long time we're lovers oh
no wait a homo break do you know what
that that was about what you said you
yeah you said DMV and then you home a
break that you knew what the dima
doesn't a lot of stuff that can go down
at the DMV though I'm excited
oh yeah yeah I never thought it'd even
be this place to meet people again I
said many people that I've never void
there have you ever started to take a
full confession I've never had sex it's
exclusively the only place I'm willing
to have sex okay sure yeah that's
amazing you were waiting in an
uncomfortable plastic chair for a very
long time so that's the first time I
like that sofa like you break that down
yeah you were waiting and an
uncomfortable plastic chair for a very
long time very rest
we had a beef we had a brief chat about
strategy to get you back in the cute boy
that's about it so the DMV here in
California you have to take a little
number that takes a long time they use
the word queue yeah there's some
thoughts okay keep doing okay come again
this third one man this is the most
northern California statement ever and
this is what made me choose I had an
acai bowls you correctly use the word
algorithm in a sentence there was
nothing more Silicon Valley
I'm also relatively sure it's a haiku
waiting in an uncomfortable plastic
chair for a very long time we have a
brief chat about strategy to get you
back in the queue you correctly use the
word algorithm in a sentence I love this
this one was art to me it's beautiful
it's definitely I could okay without
totally five seven five cursed off and
this is this is a male the female is
marked as that but holy mansplaining
Batman you correctly use the word
algorithm and those sentences there ever
been a more Silicon Valley sentence well
one of my favorite jokes about living in
this area is how people like you walk
down the street and you're just hear
someone say innovative like clout you're
just like these ones just like coughing
sentences like the GTA characters really
nice I really like
the note of you was sitting in an
uncomfortable plastic chair because
that's like a consideration or empathy
not even just that one thing expresses
also to me that's like a poetic opening
line of like a song like a song I would
love a book would feeling I never saying
I'm uncomfortable like you you met me at
a very strange time in my life so what
you saying is we want poetic Peter to
write a song so this poetic okay what it
Peter I think this first few sentences
are good I am a little frustrated at
that I'm so surprised you understood
what Calgary yeah okay so maybe he's
mentioning that in like Oh like yeah
just casually drop the one algorithm
like maybe it's not in a in a
condescending way I'm hoping so yeah I
think I'm probably I'm probably
projecting too much the story but I went
on a date this is the story about my
wants date ever I have a youtube video
about it but that was a part where we
were talking about history I'm talking
about The Hague Convention which is like
no conversation topic that we're not
we're not talking about this cherish saw
the excitement in your face back it up
but I just like we started talking about
that and he was like so that's like the
only history thing you know right that
was like he has a response to me
bringing out the Hague Convention in
conversation with tell me I never slept
with this person things but it was like
that was a thing when in a way that was
like I'm surprised you know that surely
that's like the only thing I do is super
drunk yeah he shut up drunk yeah oh and
then we went to a cocktail bar and I
thought that I looked really nice I was
wearing a nice dress and he was like we
should leave this place is like a little
bit too fancy for you yeah he was a dick
could you please tell me that in like
the most like Hollywood dramatic
nineteen thirties we possibly just were
your cocktail into his eyes I was nice
the whole time and I don't know why good
at the end of the day he invited me to
his apartment to play chess I said no
but he was like come back to my pumping
I I want to play chess okay okay well
like everything that happens as you love
the idea that you go to his apartment it
didn't he was clearly asking me so and I
do believe if I hadn't gone to his
apartment that he would have played me
in chest just to be able to beat me at
chess like I genuinely believe that I
think this was like general
I would have tried also like but only
optton to beat me at cellos I want to
see my bishop like I mean that wasn't
that kind of nice okay I genuinely think
he was a dude he was like hey I think
I'm better than you you made me insecure
by being smart at some point during this
date I want to beat you at chess
it was terrible it sounds like a joke
great yeah I was really bad so but
anyway so back to the the relevant
stories I do think that that is entirely
possible and him being impressed by us
but I think they could have also made a
joke of it like if someone like uses a
big like I've never done stupid things
Ang's and I came to this realization I
didn't know people had eyebrows until I
was 30
what yeah this whole thing is very weird
like I'm sorry yeah maybe maybe this is
wrong for the show no it's great for the
show it's just it's taken me a long time
to come to terms
yeah that's different than this okay
what's up okay no I just okay so I knew
people at eyebrows I know they have
eyelashes okay but I didn't realize they
were different I in my mind the work you
guys see my face right now they're very
confused they were the same thing I just
thought people had both but they were
one thing I didn't know they were
separate don't they look connected I
thought they were the same thing I don't
think on this path it's kind like I was
looking at the world wrong I've thought
about this yeah or probably this last
three years since he sold out a thing on
my mind I think about this every once in
a while
yeah keeps me up at night anyway Sam
people
may really odd mistakes in observation
that may Pisco is question or
fundamental course so I don't want to
make fun of the fact the guy was was
like hey you're doing what an algorithm
was I just think that if you write three
sentences about somebody and two of them
sound vaguely poetic ending up on
algorithm is maybe not the way to go I
think this is a callback number when I
said the word cute yeah and I said we
should think about that
I think he's British some American would
say cute what would you say wine
how are you saying online you're alone
thank you yeah so I think I think but
yeah you're from one of those
non-american I think this man this man
is one of the Queen's men that explains
why he's so poetic classic Pete yeah
wait this is Pete also last guy was Pete
no that was a short thick Rick I don't
know what's going on this one seems like
a guy who like had a connection with
someone that like was probably fluid
Amy's jokes they got along fairly well
he seems like he genuinely cared about
her he's not like it's not just like hey
I saw your ass and then he sucked at
dumb and I wanted to put my dick belly
right like everyone back off tick Rick
wasn't like that yeah I think Pete
sounds like a nice guy is this one going
to work actually maybe like it's
possible that if she felt the same way
off to seeing him and wasn't
condescended by his however he presented
that or than comment yeah well I I do
think that if we can go beyond the
algorithm I do think that means some of
these you have one like first story but
it's fun you know do you think love can
bloom even on a battlefield love can
bloom in the DMV it can bloom anywhere I
mean like I did to me the idea of
finding someone's DMV is the same thing
of like being in line for a bathroom at
a bar where it's like hey we're both in
this very same situation the only time
I've ever tried to like start a
conversation with a guy at a bar was
when I like I literally used that it was
like any guy that I thought was really
cute that I had made a joke with when I
was standing next to him at the bar oh
yeah he went to the line and I saw him
go and I immediately went like that was
a pretty good tragedy we had to stand
next week like I mean I didn't really
up wanting to get his number or anything
after that second conversation but it
was like still an interesting
conversation he seemed like a - I I met
my wife standing in the out-of-state
student registration line in colleague
at first I was flirting with a roommate
ignoring her alright so this is the part
where we decide which of these three we
think is most likely to walk I think
that I was gonna say that Shabbat is the
least likely to walk but thick Rick's
isn't very likely to walk you know I
think I think that yeah which is good
let me take Rick like saving big money
so maybe maybe people that have not met
the man artisan who I'm just gonna
wonder what this is a thank you I
appreciate that because I heard our
pitch is also perfect so make sure we
don't get it all right I'm going to put
thick Rick at the bottom based on the
fact that Jared brought up the point
that I don't think he even wants to meet
her he's shouting into the void
he's fantasizing about it and she if she
read that she wouldn't contact it but
he's also the other yeah but he may have
let it like a Navajo wind talker code
because some of its written out in some
of its actual yeah I'm also not a fun a
fan of sharp part to be perfectly honest
I think this is a dude who shark-shaped
which I don't think is great
no absolutely short shaving her he
posted on the [ __ ] Internet that
she's sharted in his car it didn't
mention my name
that's a very I good identifier to be
like hey you shot in my car and then so
the girl reading is like oh that's
clearly about me well she's like I'd
like to believe that if I ever went on a
date with someone that I even if I
didn't like them and they like your
first assignment cuz but it didn't
matter
or or I just thought they were great if
they crap themselves on the date I'm
reasonably sure that I would never tell
anyone even if we ended up together
after wording and I also probably
wouldn't bring it up with them again I'm
always really careful about that if
there's something that I think someone's
gonna be insecure about it's like make a
joke out of once an image
exactly I might bring it up might return
to it and would secure the relationship
might even tell our friends about it
afterward when everything is good and
hahaha and we're all having a fun dinner
together and we know these are people
who can trust me yeah maybe if you know
I was mostly like how do you ask can I
tell you a story
no you're talking about my booboo how do
you ask that
there are their stories flashing through
my head right now that I'm like these
are a great podcast material but I'm not
going to mention them yes I care about
the person I'm with and I'm not going to
tell everybody about it yeah I mean
we're not ranking them in terms of
morality it's and I think the DMV one is
the most likely to keep shot yeah cuz I
think poor Pete like I I've been at the
DMV where I've been there for like an
hour and a half and so if I was in an
hour and a half sitting right next to
someone yeah I could totally see myself
like if I met you in the DMV Marty I
would all right the only looks for me is
starting to play his base as he does
routinely every single night did you
guys not hear that no he does it oh my
god how play music till 4:00 a.m. but
drives me crazy oh that's fun no thick
Rick it might be it seems like something
oh where things
all right now I'm here in Florida well
thank you for having so much no I feel a
little thin coat pockets full suit
that's both of y'all have been on and
which brings me great joy and it's
pockets full suit calm or the you know
to plug that patreon patron
councillor petty Twitter show is not
supposed to do a show about the people
and the things we're thankful this show
when I explain it to people looks like a
paragraph looks like okay so we pick
misconnection on Craigslist we don't
tell each other what they are then we
talk about them it's kind of fun it's
kind of storytelling it's also kind of
advice what wouldn't should have
happened that's your show but no I
pockets this about mostly it's about
people were thankful for sometimes
that's frustrating I like I think of it
as grounded positivity life and is
terrible sometimes but sometimes it's
good to acknowledge both yeah those are
funny episodes are heartbreaking so it's
a real yeah sometimes a terrible but
mostly they bit yeah and I have a lot of
fun doing it and have great guests and
con people it's for you so that's what I
do you find me on Twitter any comment
Jared and I spend a lot of time on there
telling dumb jokes that I think are
funny and trying to say nice things
occasionally I like the Twitter space
that's me I'm at McKinney MCB IgG IgE
TTY and if I'm young shows a lot of edge
again including Beyond and unlocked yeah
I am Charl on design with its it's just
Charles I with my name in the middle of
it what's a Charizard it's a Pokemon
interesting that posture yeah like a
digital monster yeah